Brad Pitt is speaking out for the very
first time about this split from
Angelina Jolie his interview with GQ
style is honest vulnerable the actor
addresses issues like his drinking and
reveals how the one time a list couples
six kids are doing he's very open their
split in the fall shocked the world pitt
and Jolie had been together more than
ten years and things turned ugly fast
with rumors running rampant in courts
getting involved now he says quote I was
really on my back and changed to a
system when Child Services was called
it's just very very jarring for the kids
to suddenly have their family ripped
apart brad says he and Angelina are both
now quote doing their best to work
things out the actor also gets candid
about what he calls running from his
feelings he says quote I can't remember
a day since I got out of college when I
wasn't boozing or had a spliff or
something this last year you know things
I wasn't dealing with I was boozing too
much it's just become a problem the
timeline on that would mean that Brad's
drinking became an issue seemingly
during the marriage he and angelina
announced their split only about seven
months ago in September Pitt reveals
he's now in therapy and says he quote
loves it
it seems improvements are being made a
source told et about a week ago that
Pitt recently had his first overnight
visit with his kids since the break-up
and another source tells et that neither
Pitt nor Jolie are dating anyone right
now
but that Pitt has been spending time out
with friends for more on the actor
including how he's using arts to heal
head to et online.com
you